buscando la sombra y disfrutando de un
día de verano
hemos inventado un verbo el verbo de
rasear venimos al sol nos relajamos es
amistoso estamos entre amigos estamos
muy contentos
en parís como enagás hace calor una
pequeña copa con vistas al famoso
campanario aquí no se puede pedir más
ningún apartamento muy bonito pero no
tengo alcohol así que mi balcón está
aquí es la terraza vámonos encanta el
sol cuanto más calor hace más feliz soy
chris joe algunos disfrutan del sol bajo
su sombrilla pero para otros las altas
temperaturas son más difíciles de
soportar estos trabajadores necesitan
mantenerse hidratados en todo momento
para llenar sus botellas tienen un
refrigerador en natural y eficaz no hay
nada mejor que esto se mantiene fresco y
se mantiene fresco durante mucho tiempo
llevar cargas pesadas bajo el sol de
verano es algo a lo que están
acostumbrados pero no tan pronto como
estamos en mayo y empieza a hacer mucho
calor como será en julio de agosto
en otro cajón también se superaron los
30 grados en esta finca vinícola los
temporeros han traído sombreros y crema
solar en los próximos días llegarán una
hora antes a las seis y media una
decisión tomada por la gerente para
proteger a su equipo
con la previsión del clima empieza a
hacer mucho calor a las 11 de la mañana
así que por la tarde es beneficioso que
nadie trabaje de 2 a 4 de la tarde que
es el momento del día en que más calor
hace mayo podría ser un mes histórico
con temperaturas 27 grados celsius por
encima de la media estación